há 8 pessoas rodando comigo pelo mundo
nenhuma sabia falar inglês
ninguém sabe Descobri que meu fotógrafo
não falava francês
Olá como estás bem disso não estou lá na
França testando lá luz do teatro as
empresta o som ei ah ah som toda vez eu
chego antes e teste é o olho para o lado
também o faltar do parado
e eu vi nenhum francês aqui no ouvido
dele não falando aqui tá um dizer que é
e ele entendendo que ele não isso aí não
acontece aqui nossa que é isso é
inadimissível aqui a gente fez isso aí
botou para fora que acabou a história
não ia olhando aqui
show Beto fala francês
Eu já ouvi ele falando cérebro
E aí
e
como é que fala francês a pessoa que
fala registro
oi oi